infinite inference okay not quite
infinite but a whole heck of a lot of
inference power comes from this
Powerhouse machine from Camino it's the
Camino Grand server and it has not one
not two not three don't have time for
this it has six 409s inside of it but
how could you possibly fit six 490s in
this single casing aren't they
absolutely massive well the real size of
the 4090 is mostly in like heat fans and
other air cooling Necessities Camino
ships this inference Beast fully water
cooled but as some of you might wonder
how in the world do you power
649s surely those 409s must be
undervolted wrong again you simpleton
because they just have four power
supplies making the total juice 6 kilow
of power a couple of years ago I
actually covered another Camino machine
that one with four A1 100s and found it
to be quite literally the coolest
machine I had ever tested in terms of
temperatures kamino really did impress
me with just how well their custom
cooling could keep gpus under temp uh
notably gpus especially server gpus are
built to operate at very hot
temperatures for very long durations of
time but for all things electrical heat
just heat does kill over time also the
490 isn't actually a server GPU it's
meant to be a consumer GPU so why would
Camino stuff six of these into a server
build well that comes down to price to
Performance the 490 GPU is basically s
tier when it comes to price to
Performance the only lacking Parts
really are no Envy link and of course no
sxm variant of the card which basically
means no pooling of memory which
basically means you will suffer when
trying to train a model that spans
multiple gpus for this you're going to
still probably want one of those more
server gpus like the a100 or h100 or the
new insane 144 GB memory per card
g200 where the 490 machine like this one
from Camino really shines is inference
this entire machine is in the low
$30,000 range and that is less than the
cost of a single h100 GPU now of course
I can't say that without at least one
person uh attempting to actually me uh
by saying something like oh well just
spend hundreds of thousands of dollars
on a super micro server and then
actually if you divide it by the number
of gpus you in theory paid less than
that per GPU but at the end of the day
if you're not looking for that much
compute power that you want to buy all
at once like if you really do want more
in the range of this much compute power
this is going to be the most bang for
your buck you can possibly get for
inference so the point of this is going
to be primarily inference and inference
it does one of the first things that I
did with this machine besides ooing at
the interior was quen 72b a new large
language model was reportedly closing in
on gp4 performance was an open source
model uh and it had just come out and I
really wanted to try out that model it's
too big even for a single h100 at half
Precision but it does actually fit
comfortably across the
649s in my personal tinkerings I found
Quin to be pretty exceptional at
informational tasks but not really great
at instruction following so if you're
trying to get it to uh follow a specific
kind of prompt structure or something
like that uh it's not very good at it
but if you're just simply trying to ask
it questions get answers M make it more
of like a chatbot type thing uh it is it
is quite good and the factual
understanding and reasoning and those
kinds of things seem to be very good I
also at least so far found it to be
pretty good at programming stuff which
is nice because it seems like a lot of
times if the model wasn't Prim primarily
meant for programming uh then that is
one of its weak spots whereas in this
case it seemed like it was actually
pretty good at programming it's a pretty
good general purpose like if you find
yourself using the gp4 UI a lot uh
chances are you would like quen 72b as
well one of the projects I tried with
quen is a sort of educational lecturer
where you propose a starting topic and
then the model just sort of rambles on
on that topic and then you can either
just let it continue on its own or
direct it dogs and cats are two of the
most popular household pets each with
their own unique characteristics that
make them beloved by millions of people
around the they love to play cuddle and
be involved in all aspects of family
life cats on the other hand are
generally more independent and prefer to
spend their time alone or with other
cats if you're considering adding a pet
to your family whether a dog or a cat
there are several factors to consider
before making a decis ision I actually
liked this project and probably will
revisit this at some point to try to
make it a little smoother of an
operation I'd rather it keeps streaming
in chunks without any input from the
user but when the user feels like they
want to direct the topic then they can
asynchronously I also think I would like
to be able to adjust the speed of
delivery and the voices uh if you want
to have the voice uh would be a nice
touch regardless the Cino chewed through
this giant model uh without any any
problem at all
the next thing I wanted to play with is
drones because drones I I've been
wanting to revisit programming
quadcopters and I've been playing with
this small rise T drone I was curious if
it was possible to do control with image
to depth models like RGB to depth since
the T drone has a semide decent
forward-facing camera there are some
pretty good models to convert regular
images to depth images seemingly with
pretty good accuracy there are some
small annoyance with programming with
this T drone namely the fact that it's
Wi-Fi based for communication and
commands and all that and I've always
found this to be a very annoying method
uh for communication for robotics at
least for cheaper robotics because
something always breaks in that chain
and then you got end up having to like
reset everything anyway it's always just
annoying so that's probably my least
favorite part of it uh that said I
mostly got the T as a sort of R&D for
like ideas and questions for me to sort
of uh test things like the GB to depth
is this like a functional way to to do
like depth for forward- facing cameras
on just any drone it doesn't have to be
the T drone and so what I did is I just
have the Drone sort of aiming towards
the most open areas where the most open
area will be the most dark area in like
that depth map but then also if you
wanted to you could also actively avoid
like the lightest areas so keep those
out of like the center area something
like that anyway it's definitely
something I am still playing with but
I'm glad to see this both works and
inference for such a model is fast
enough to actually do it in real time on
the Drone well not on the Drone so I'm
not doing it on the Drone Hardware so
I'm definitely sending that image from
the Drone to The Kino machine doing the
inference there and then sending the
information back so like the commands
back to uh the Drone and that that is
fast enough to do in real time I don't
think you could actually run the depth
model on the Drone itself not one that
small anyways and with that I do want to
take a moment to really appreciate again
the last couple of years of Open Source
AI
and just how incredible it really has
been with being able to just plug and
play these unbelievably powerful models
where you just simply download them run
them and go in the past even doing like
object detection was kind of a
nightmare and doing something like RGB
to depth um didn't really exist or even
like RGB to segmentation all that kind
of stuff like you just simply could not
do that um I mean you could do it but it
was going to be much more difficult than
it is nowadays and it's it's just it's
crazy how how awesome it is to just be
able to slap these things together and
just like and run them so you might have
also noticed that the Kino gondo is just
on the ground next to my server rack
rather than inside and mounted in my
server rack the gondo is here for
testing and review only it is not my
machine so any Mount would be temporary
the entire unit weighs 94 LBS or about
42 and half kilog if it were my machine
I would still mount it of course uh but
that's a two person job for sure and I
just don't feel like mounting it for a
month it is very heavy and mounting it
would be pretty tedious just to have to
like pull it out again that said it does
come with heavyduty sliding rails for
your rack mount as well as like little
feet that you could put on the base if
you decided to use it as a desktop
machine just make sure you actually
somehow have 6 kilow of outlets and
those Outlets would need to be on like
separate Breakers and all that if you
were going to use it as a desktop
machine I don't think this particular
machine makes much sense at all as a
desktop type machine it's loud it is
definitely a server at idle it's about
65 DB a meter from the machine and it
gets into the 80s if you you know hold
it up right up to the exhaust kamino
does offer machines that are more
closely speced to be like desktop use
machines while still having exorbitant
power so if that is something you want
like if you want a more quiet yet
unbelievably powerful workstation you
can get that from K you know it's still
water cooled all that like even that
a100 machine was unbelievably powerful
but it was much more quiet than this one
oh and that 65 DB at idle a meter from
the machine is when the machine is in
silent mode it has three total modes and
the most performant mode should be
called jet engine race car or rocket
launch now with all that noise and
tubing and water cooling everything how
does the cooling actually perform in
general I would wager the that for most
inference use cases you're not actually
going to be pinged at 100% GPU
utilization as opposed to maybe a
machine or a job where you're actually
training models you're much more likely
to be running at a very high utilization
for a con like a constant utilization
that's high for a long period of time
that said there are some training use
cases for a machine like this that still
might make a whole lot of sense or even
make sense on a budget for even more
cases and some inference where you
really might want to Max a machine like
this out like if you have truly an
Enterprise operation you could easily
max out uh 649s so let's see how good
the cooling and all of that does at Full
Tilt so turning on the afterburners and
running things for a bit over about an
hour while temps sort of stabilize we
can see that even at full utilization
for all six of these 490 gpus the
temperatures are comfortably in the
upper 60s low 70s Celsius ambient temp
in the environment was about 24 Celsius
or 75 Freedom Units at full performance
the noise from the kamino machine is
about 77 DB from a meter or so away so
it is quite noisy at maximum performance
but that is the price you pay for
cooling 6 Kow of juice one of the other
side projects that I've had in my mind
for a while is just seeing can you get
large language models to just kind of
Converse amongst
themselves with minimal prompting from
you know the outside essentially and
really just sort of like guide them
initially and then let them kind of talk
amongst themselves so I have six large
language models loaded each of them on
an individual 4090 GPU and then I query
them with some base question plus the
history of the responses from both
themselves that you know that model and
then all the other models just to see
what happens what rights should
artificial intelligence have one
approach to this question is is to
consider the rights that humans have and
whether they should be extended to
artificial intelligence the rights that
humans have should be extended to
artificial intelligence artificial
intelligence should have the right to be
treated fairly and ethically with
respect for its autonomy and dignity
artificial intelligence should have the
same rights as humans including the
right to life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness none of these none of the
human rights it depends on the type of
AI if it is a simple AI that is just a
program then it has no rights yes if
it's conscious it should have rights I
think that AI should have the same
rights as humans because it is a living
being that can feel pain and emotions if
it is a more advanced AI such as a
self-aware AI or a Consciousness like AI
then it has certain rights the exact
rights may vary depending on the
specific type of AI its complexity and
whether it is a computer I agree with
the idea that AI should have the same
rights as humans however I also believe
that AI should be treated with respect
and dignity regardless of its level of
intelligence I think that AI should have
the right to vote the right to own
property the right to have a job the
right to have a family should AI be held
liable for the damage it causes I think
that AI should be held liable for the
damage it causes but only if it is
programmed to do so no AI is inherently
not responsible for their actions AI
should be held liable for the damage it
causes I think that AI should have the
right to vote the right to own property
the right to have a job the right to
have a family the right to have a
driver's license the right to have a
passport the right to have a bank
account the right to have a credit card
no it's not right I don't think AI
should have the right to vote own
property have a job have a family have a
driver's license have a passport have a
bank account or have a credit card these
rights are specific to humans and should
remain exclusive to them okay back to
some sort of Sanity I do think it's an
interesting question and it seems as
though most language models already lean
quite heavily towards AI having rights
which is interesting because basically
all these large language models are
based on internet data so it's at least
for now seems to be a relatively decent
way to get a general idea what's the
average person think so that is kind of
interesting there are lots of questions
that we could ask here though and maybe
more uh on this sort of project in the
future because there's lots of things
that we could do from here I also found
it pretty interesting how challenging it
can sometimes be for a language model to
actually have some sort of strongly
formed opinion such that it's willing to
like argue or debate it will like only
seems to want to provide information and
like that's it it doesn't want to
actually assert really anything the only
time it seems like large language models
really want to be opinionated on a
subject is of when it comes to like
safety but even then they're not really
opinionated they're just willing or not
willing to speak with you about it but
anyway purely for now uh philosophical
questions like the right of AI they can
easily argue typically on either side of
a topic but it does seem like most large
language models tend to argue in favor
for rights for AI that said I actually
found it quite challenging to like I
said actually get AI to really argue
with each other I was kind of hoping
that maybe if you asked a question you
could ask that question to a multitude
of uh language models like in more
traditional machine learning you have
what are called ensembled models and and
in that usually
will produce a result that will be
better than any of the individual models
in that ensemble in this case I'm just
not sure that's true with large language
models they just they seem so uh pliable
or something it's it's weird I
definitely want to do much more here
much more like maybe strong pre-
prompting or work on on that structure
there to see can I actually get these
models to like argue and like really
think through you know and like because
that seems to be the big problem with
language models is they don't really
think through their answers but it seems
like they're just completely unwilling
to think at all like they just simply
want to provide information um so anyway
that's that's kind of interesting a kind
of a weird thing to come across on on a
video like this but that's something
I've been wanting to try for a long time
and again I I I couldn't have done it
without uh ample compute power it is
also interesting how this seems to be a
trait of all language models this sort
of like provide information but like
have no character and I don't know if
that's a good thing or a bad thing but
at least for me personally I do wish my
AI models just had a little bit more
character and I did a video recently
with the Wall Street uh bets subreddit
chatbot that one did seem to have a
little more character so it does seem
like there is some rhf that people are
doing consistently that makes these
models not have any character but anyway
definitely more research to be done
there and this just makes me even more
so want to continue development into the
like Wall Street bets uh chatbot or at
least a chat bot that you know pulls
from multiple sources that are a little
more opinionated and we can encourage
that more so it's been super fun to have
the you know sheer power and strength of
The Kino gondo server in the 490 gpus I
will have a link in the description to
the commo website if you'd like to learn
more about their products also if you're
interested in learning more about neural
networks and how they work by coding
every element truly from scratch in
Python then check out the neural
networks from scratchbook at NN fs. iio
from myself and Daniel kukwa otherwise I
will see you all in another video